The topic of aggression is of great importance in our lives. In fact, there's
not way around it that we experience aggression in our lives. And other animals
engage in aggressive behavior to get the resources that they want. So, we can
define aggression as violent behavior that is intended to cause psychological
or physical harm, or both, to another individual or being. Now, why are we
aggressive? Chances are, we're often aggressive because we've been provoked.
And we engage in aggressive behavior because we've been provoked by feelings of
anger. We call that hostile aggression. I'll be honest with you and then share
an experience of hostile aggression that I had last week when I was walking at
the campus. I was crossing the street and I had the walk sign. And another car
came around and almost hit me. Now as a frequent pedestrian, this was not the
first time it almost happened to me, but I was very upset. And I started to
yell at the driver, and I had a few choice words to say to him. Now my
hostility was limited in anger to yelling at the person. But in some cases, we
see people, maybe more aggressive, and try to hit the person or chase after the
car. In fact, the term road rage has been developed to explain such hostility
the driver sometimes experience.